[Music]
tonight on Brian Ross investigates the
Saudi crackdown on dissidents and
journalists he refused to toe the line
to shut up to take the King's shilling
even comedians are a target Saudi Arabia
was basically the boy band manager of
9/11 they didn't write the songs but
they helped get the group together and a
shout out to the journalism that exposed
a sweetheart deal for a billionaire sex
offender the work he ended up leading to
was a joke the sentence he served it was
even a bigger joke and then his
probation was a slap in everybody's face
from the law and crime Network studios
in New York this is Brian Ross
investigates and good evening welcome to
our premium broadcast tonight we
investigate how dictators and despots
are said to be using the latest in high
technology to track down those who dare
to speak out against them what are the
same social media that has given an
unfiltered voice to dissidents it's now
being used to find them to imprison them
and in some cases to kill them at the
heart of the Arab Spring the movement
that released decades have disgust and
anger with corrupt and brutal leaders
was the ability for instant
communication with cell phones social
media like Twitter that has been the
double-edged sword that is the
double-edged sword of social media Sara
Lee whitson of Human Rights Watch a tool
that allowed citizens to communicate
with each other without the filter of
their government propaganda media that
allowed them to exchange opinions that
allowed the most importantly to share
information has been turned against them
sometimes with blunt instruments where
the Internet is just turned off but
governments can't sustain that for too
long because then their internet is also
turned off to surveillance you know and
surveillance technology sold by Western
companies by Israeli companies that
allows them to violate all manners of
the privacy of their citizens to surveil
them and then to
them in jail the company in Israel that
makes that software says it's only used
by governments to track criminals and
terrorists well obviously that's not the
case
witson cites the case of the saudi
journalists jamal khashoggi lord of his
country's embassy in turkey and then
killed by a security team that american
intelligence officials say reported to
the Saudi Crown Prince according to a
report from a research group at the
University of Toronto Koosh oh geez
phone calls to a fellow dissident were
being tracked with sophisticated
surveillance technology software sewed
by an Israeli company obviously we know
that this technology was used to
infiltrate the telephone of a Saudi
activist who's now in Canada and in fact
what he said is that this is how the
government was able to view and monitor
all of his whatsapp exchanges with
jimana shoji and so do you think that
was a factor in how they were able to
figure out how they would lure him to
the embassy in Turkey I think that he
believes and at the time Jamal felt that
it certainly revealed the extent to
which he was critical of the Saudi
government perhaps even more critical
than he had otherwise publicly stated
and so it was definitely a breach of his
personal opinions whether they would
have tried to entrap and kill him
otherwise probably and now the death of
Khashoggi has rallied human rights
groups around the world to demand the
Saudis and those companies they say help
them track dissidents to come clean
about how they operate he refused to toe
the line to shut up
to take the King's shilling had he done
so he'd be rich and very much alive
today but Jamal wouldn't play the game
these leaders do not hesitate to cut
down thousands of people to restrain all
of us and our freedom and sustain the
status quo the reasons for draconian
rules and respects are purely selfish
they wish to remain in power eternally
and they wish to enjoy
wealth illegally your voice is only
amplified in your death or or to your
real-life whisper reaching millions more
than you might have ever dreamed of
reaching 2 million Twitter followers ha
that's nothing to the audience you have
commanded and raised up today and as for
Twitter based in San Francisco Human
Rights Watch says it has lots of
questions about its practices in the
wake of Cody's murder they have a duty
to ensure that the information of their
users is kept confidential that the
information of their users is not shared
or breached by governments and we know
for example specifically in the case of
Twitter that there was a Saudi spy who
actually infiltrated into Twitter was
elevated in the ranks as an engineer
there and was believed to be surveilling
the true identities the personal
information of Saudi Twitter users so
they had somebody inside Twitter in
their Middle East operation they did
have someone inside Twitter and he was
subsequently fired in a statement to
Brian Ross investigates a Twitter
spokesperson said we rigorously limit
access to sensitive account information
to a very small group of employees with
extensive security and privacy training
no other personnel have the ability to
access this information regardless of
where they operate and none of these
teams are based within the Middle East
region twitter says it does not
knowingly give that sort of information
to any government do you accept that no
we don't accept it we know that they
sell their information they sell the
sliced and diced information at
different tiers at different levels
sometimes to private users but what
protections do they put in place to
ensure that those private users don't in
turn pass it on to governments and
witson says they believe one of the
crown prince's closest advisors so al
Kitani implicated in the murder of
journalists Khashoggi had an arrangement
to receive some of that Twitter
information from the private company he
bragged about having a troll army of
flies to attack dissidents
he bragged about being Lord of the Flies
he tweeted threats to Saudis who were
criticizing the government on Twitter to
say we can get you we have secret ways
of getting you so this is something that
the Saudi government has publicly
bragged about but is it fair to blame
Twitter for that well this is not about
blame this has happened right
Twitter was infiltrated by a Saudi agent
the identities of Twitter users have
reportedly been disclosed a number of
those people apparently are now in jail
detained unjustly so Twitter has a duty
to speak out against this to condemn the
arrests of twitter users for their
tweets and to make reparations to people
who were injured by things that happened
inside twitter twitter says it does not
provide information if it's going to be
used to surveil its users in a statement
to us a twitter spokesman said we
understand the incredible risk faced by
many who use our service to hold power
to account and we have strong tools in
place to protect their privacy and their
ability to do their vital work we have
forged partnerships with human rights
organizations around the world who
inform our company-wide approach to
these issues as for the Saudi government
we've been asking for a response to our
questions for several weeks but we have
yet to hear from them the crown prince
has said publicly that he deplores the
murder of jamal kesaji
calling it painful to all Saudis painful
to every human in the world but remember
American intelligence officials believe
the people responsible for custody's
murder reported directly to the crown
prince and we have certainly seen even
since the killing of khashoggi just how
sensitive the Saudi government is to any
suggestion of criticism just this month
when this 18 year old Saudi woman
attempted to flee her family to escape
which she said was serious abuse Saudi
officials trapped her to Thailand and
attempted to have her forcibly returned
home human rights groups intervened and
the Saudis were forced to relent and now
she has settled in Canada and even
comedians seem to be threatening to the
Saudi Kingdom the Saudis actually
demanded that Netflix pull one
particular comment Hasan Minhaj off its
feed to Saudi Arabia here's some of what
the Saudis did not want their citizens
to see remember America hates terrorists
Saudi Arabia gave them passports Saudi
Arabia was basically the boy band
manager of 9/11 they didn't write the
songs but they helped get the group
together suddenly America's marriage of
convenience with Saudi Arabia is
starting to feel outdated to learn more
about how Saudi Arabia and other
governments are trying to turn social
media against those who use it to speak
out we are joined now by Bill Maher sack
who works for the citizen lab at the
University of Toronto a group that does
research on social media
bill thanks for being here tell me how
you first got onto this subject thanks
for having me Brian well so I started
investigating surveillance and spyware
back in 2012 actually when I was looking
into some suspicious emails received by
activists in Bahrain and ever since then
I've been working with the citizen lab
to uncover
sort of a vast industry of companies
that's so technology for surveillance to
governments around the world and then
the government's instead of using this
to you know perhaps spy on terrorists or
criminals
turn around and use this to repress
dissidents and journalists and this
group at Israel you focused on them
tell me about what they sell and how
they do it so NSO group is one of the
companies in this burgeoning commercial
surveillance industry and they sell a
product called Pegasus which is a mobile
phone spyware product in other words a
government will purchase Pegasus on and
then they'll be able to send text
messages to phones and if the target
clicks on a link inside the text message
then their phone becomes infected with
Pegasus and the government agency is
able to see everything on the phone
including pictures private text messages
listening in on phone calls seeing
passwords and even turning on the
microphone and webcam of the phone in
order to spy on the vicinity any sort of
conversation
meetings that are going on it'd be
effective going after criminals but do
they also use it you believe in going
after dissidents those who speak out
against the government yes that's
definitely what we've seen in our
research and of course you know
governments like like Saudi Arabia or in
other cases we've found this you know
similar products being abused by
governments like Ethiopia the
government's will come out and say look
you know we consider this person a
terrorist and you know one man's
terrorist is another man's journalist
and certainly we see countries like
Saudi Arabia considering basic descent
things that in the United States we'd
consider as a freedom of speech they
consider it terrorism because it
threatens where they see is threatening
their monopoly on power bill let me read
you a statement that NSL just sent us
about this broadcast they say we license
our technology to government
intelligence and law enforcement
agencies to provide them the tools they
need to prevent and investigate
terrorism and crime thousands of lives
have been saved through the use of this
technology which has helped prevent
terrorist attacks stop drug and sex
trafficking rings and rescue kidnapped
children what do you say to that well to
the extent that the technology is
actually being used for that I think
that's great
assuming this is happening under you
know proper oversight and everything
like that right certainly what we've
uncovered in our extensive research on
NSA group is a troubling pattern where
multiple clients so clients that we
believe are linked to Saudi Arabia
Mexico the United Arab Emirates are all
using this product to target journalists
and activists simply for you know what
they say or the way that they say it
specifically because they say things
that are you know perhaps going against
the government's position so you know to
the extent that this is being used
against terrorists and serious criminals
I think that that is great but there's
clearly a problem here as long they say
they have no involvement whatsoever in
the murder of the journalists Jamarcus
oh gee is there any evidence to the
tray well so with regard to NSO group
specifically there are you know a lot of
unknowns that we can't really know from
a purely technical analysis so what we
do know from the technical side is that
if we have very high confidence that the
phone of a Canadian dissident who was
regularly talking with Jamarcus OG was
infected with Pegasus and a Saudi wrench
operator was spying on more would have
had the opportunity to spawn pretty much
everything on that phone now did NSO
group know that this was going on that's
hard to say because we don't know from a
technical point of view to what extent
and it so is looking over the shoulders
of its clients so how do you limit or
curb the use of this by people are using
it for a nefarious purposes that
crackdown on dissidents and criticism
well I think that's a great question and
I think that you know one of the ways to
do that is if you're a company like NSO
group look at you know who your
customers so if you're selling to you
know for instance maybe like a Western
country that has you know perhaps
stronger institutions that can oversee
any sort of government surveillance well
that's that's one thing but if you're
going to sell to a government like like
Saudi Arabia or like the United Arab
Emirates where you know we're talking
about pretty much absolutely
dictatorships where there really is no
no oversight over the surveillance and
the law is essentially what you know the
ruling family says the law is so in
those sorts of cases you've got to
expect that there's going to be abuse
you produced a map a worldwide map
showing these red countries what do they
indicate well so we released a report at
citizen lab showing countries in which
we found evidence that there were one or
more victims in other words people who
were infected with Pegasus in that
country now these are not necessarily in
all cases governments which are have
purchased the system or are using the
system you know we can't see that from a
technical point of view but what we
Chansey is the location of where these
these infected devices are and saudis
are using it outside of Saudi Arabia
that is what it appears yes so our
results from our internet wide scanning
to find these victims showed that the
operator which we call kingdom which
we've linked to Saudi Arabia appears to
be spying in 12 countries including
Canada Turkey the UK France and a bunch
of countries across the Middle East so
they're tracking their citizens who are
publicly criticizing them is that what
you draw on that well so we can't
necessarily say in each case whether the
target is you know a dissident or a
journalist ER or who exactly they are
you know what we have been able to
uncover from getting in touch with
potentially targeted communities around
the world as we've been able to find
people's phones where they've received
these text messages containing the links
which are the tell-tale sign of a
Pegasus so we found Saudi dissidents in
Canada and in the United Kingdom who
have been targeted with these links
there was also a report from Amnesty
International last year where they
identified that one of their staffers at
Amnesty actually received one of these
sms's and we're able to connect that to
the the kingdom operator which is there
to Saudi Arabia how much are these
government's paying for this Pegasus
software well in case of any specific
government of course those documents are
under wraps and hard to get to but based
on leaked documents that we've seen and
reports in the news media it appears
that when MSO group is selling the
system they pitch it you know a price
tag somewhere in the order of you know
high tens of millions or low hundreds of
millions and it winds up you know being
sold again according to these leaked
documents to roughly that price perhaps
paid over a period of a few years that's
a huge figure a lot of money at stake
bill Martha thank you very much for
joining us thanks so much when we come
back a shout-out for some outstanding
journalists
I will billionaire sex offender in Miami
avoiding a long prison term
and now a shout-out to recognize some of
the excellent investigative reporting
being done around the country that often
doesn't get as much recognition as it
deserves today a shout-out to the Miami
Herald for its explosive investigation
into how this billionaire convicted sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein
was able to get what was essentially a
slap on the wrist for abusing dozens of
underage girls we didn't really know how
many there were I mean part of this
story is how much was kept secret in in
the court documents reporter Julie Brown
spent more than a year tracking down the
young women who were Epstein's victims I
probably spoke with about eight and of
those eight only four wanted to go on
the you know courageous enough to go on
the record in a powerful video Brown
produced with her partner Emily miss
show we were underage we were little
girls I was 16 I was 16 I started going
to him when I was like 14 15 14 turning
15 if you think at 14 $200 that's a lot
of money at 14 years olds I mean that's
a lot of money now and then Brown spent
countless hours doing journalism the old
fashioned tried-and-true way to learn
about the lenient deal federal
prosecutors cut with Epstein requiring
him to serve only 13 months in the
county jail these are 10 to 12 years
worth of documents there was probably
thousands if not tens of thousands of
documents to wade through but the
turning point came Brown says when two
key police officials trusted her enough
to lay out what really happened behind
the scenes it started out and given me
in a backrub but many cases it turned
into something far worse than that
elevated to a crime and a serious crime
that what he had a plane to was a joke
the sentence he served it was even a
bigger joke and then his probation was a
slap in everybody's face I think once
the police chief was willing to go on
the record with me and the
lead detective both of them had never
given interviews before and I think
after we did their interviews we really
realize how how good of a story we had
and it went to the heart of how much
influence Epstein had and how he and his
the people that work for him
bullied everyone associated with this
case and look who knows what else is
going to come out I mean that the
excellent journalism is now has spread
the message it's not just a state court
case that stuck in Palm Beach County now
people are really aware of what's going
on Browns reporting raised questions
about the federal prosecutor at the time
Alex Acosta who is now the Secretary of
Labor in the Trump administration he
seemed to go to great lengths to cut a
lenient deal with Epstein and keep the
whole process secret according to Brown
Acosta defended the deal during his
Senate confirmation hearings the stet
mr. Epstein should plead guilty to two
years register as a sex offender and
concede liability so the victims could
get restitution and if that were done
the federal interest would be satisfied
and we would refer to the states
Brown got no comment from Epstein nor
did we but one of his lawyers Alan
Dershowitz told me he was proud of the
deal he made for his client so no
regrets then in arranging a deal in
which he spent only 13 months behind
only 10 months I mean the job of
criminal defense lawyers to get the best
possible you know if I had been able to
get him a deal where he spent no time in
prison that would have been even better
members of Congress have now asked for a
full investigation of the deal in the
wake of Julie Browns reporting and she
is continuing on the story knowing that
her efforts made a difference and gave
Epstein's young victims a sense of
justice that the Department of Justice
did not they were made to believe that
they were prostitutes
so they finally said someone's finally
understanding that we weren't
prostitutes we were girls he violated us
maybe now something will change I think
they're still hoping for for a sense of
justice that something will be done in
the case and so our shout out this week
to Julie brown Emily misho and the Miami
Herald that's our program for this week
thanks for joining us we'll be back
again next week